none of them knew how this journey would
end their dignity and determination took
them to America now within 48 hours of
getting here seeking justice for their
son an invitation to the White House
just keeping our fingers crossed bits
we're not going to go and just have a
affair there Pat's on the back they
arrived in Washington not knowing who
they'd meet as they entered the White
House grounds they were told it was
president Trump and there was someone
else he was very gracious very welcoming
the bombshell was dropped not soon
enough to be walked in the room and
cyclists was in the building and was
willing to meet with us we made it very
clear that as we've said all along we
will meet with her and we are still
willing to see her we would still love
to to meet with her but it has to be on
our terms and on UK soil and so khulus
claimed diplomatic immunity and returned
to America after a crash that killed
19-year old Harry Dunne in a round of TV
interviews in the u.s. his parents
appealed to the president to send her
back they were told that that would
never happen but Harry's mum made a
direct appeal to the most powerful man
in the world I said if it was your 19
year old son or your son no matter what
age you would be doing the same as me
and he was holding my hand at the time
and he said yes I would and he said
maybe we'll try and push this from a
different angle we just met the
president and we never thought we'd get
this far he seems to say to me but as we
don't know if we've got any further
if the White House hoped for a happy
resolution they misjudged the search for
truth started when Harry's family spoke
to Sky News in their small village in
Northamptonshire twelve days later they
are here at the White House if nothing
more is done by the president Harry's
family will continue to explore all of
their legal options on both sides of the
Atlantic
Lisa Dowd Sky News Washington